[Music]
how have the past two years been it's
trite i know but i'm pretty sure we had
high expectations from this decade when
it comes to anime the first year 2020
has had a rough start i've got to admit
but overall have your expectations been
met to start the decade off we've got so
many hits already that i won't be able
to list them all instead for today i'm
going to be talking about 10 of my
favorite and what i think are the best
new action anime in this decade i'm
going to be considering both my personal
enjoyment and a show's effect on the
community how well it's received and
such when making the list whether you're
here for the sake of watching a year in
review video or looking for something
relatively new to watch you are in the
right place also i'm not going to be
including sequels here so we can get
these new rising stars some shine
kicking off the list we have 2020's
decadence at my number 10.
[Music]
decadence was quite the ambitious
project by studio nut airing around the
midpoint of the year 2020 in a very
packed season thanks to all the previous
delays it kind of flew under the radar
for the most part never mind the three
big sequels that it had the misfortune
of airing alongside there's the really
hyped god of high school great pretender
and rent a girlfriend to contend with
however for an action sci-fi show that
looked like an offshoot to those attack
on titan-like shows at first it truly
came into its own a few episodes into
its run for something that's not so
popular the team did a stellar job in
terms of production and it's a lot
deeper than people initially gave it
credit for can't be helped with the
rough or generic looking start but after
finishing it i'd say that i came out
more than satisfied with the character
dynamics and the messages in the show it
probably won't get a second season but
really it doesn't need one
[Music]
you know a lot of the popular action
titles in the past few years have been
in the form of isakai anime but how
about playing the role of the isekai
protagonist yourself and assembling your
allies rising up the ranks and
conquering a land ravaged by factions
competing for supremacy dying is only
the beginning welcome to the world of
re-fantasia charm and conquer the
sponsors of this video reed fantasia
charm and conquer is the hot new rpg in
town putting you in the role of an
isekai protagonist destined for
greatness but to get to the fight for
supremacy you have to gather your allies
and this my friends is by far my
favorite part of the game you know i'm a
sucker for these waifu collector games
and re-fantasia is no exception the
character art is nothing short of
awesome and it gives me more motivation
to get to know and recruit these
characters who can range from cute to
sexy it's the newest batch in the whole
city builder waifu collector genre so if
you're a fan of this kind of gameplay
you should check this game out it helps
that the game just launched not too long
ago so catching up to the rest of the
player base isn't a problem at all join
the fun by clicking the download link in
the description you can also use the
bonus code for some nifty items that
will come in handy i'm looking forward
to seeing you in game and i hope that we
can have lots of fun memories together
however if you prefer popcorn
entertainment look no further from
misfit of demon king academy in our
number 9 spot
[Music]
foreign
terms of easy access or how easy it is
to get a random guy to watch and enjoy a
show for dumb mindless fun misfit of
demon king academy is my pick not just
for its season but also for its year in
what seems to be one of the last big
hits out of a bygone genre misfit of
demon king academy managed to stand out
and not fall into irrelevance like
around half of the similar stuff flying
around in the early to mid 2010s how so
by taking the overpowered main character
trope and going all overdrive with it
making the thing look so self-aware to
the point of parody while weaving actual
drama and exciting moments in between
them in a way it feels like akashic
records another similar setting that
people cared about amidst the sea of
magic academy shows that we used to get
like five of every season a decade ago
overall it's a show that knows it
doesn't take itself seriously and just
provides a lot of mindless fun coming us
with a lot of power fantasy tropes and
some of the best character and power
designs for the genre it is more than
that however and does come up with some
compelling arcs despite the main
character pretty much being the
spiritual successor of god tsuya
at number eight is a personal favorite
of mine glycemia
i'm not sure how big of a hit death game
survival shows are to you all but
gleibnir has been one of the surprises
of his season i might be a bit biased
because i also like darwin's game and
battle game in five seconds but amongst
those shows i'd say the glyph near was
the one that stood out the most if we're
talking general anime community in
contrast to decadence library took
advantage of all those delays it's just
perception and all but with the big
hitters in its genre mostly out of the
way a lot more people tuned in to glide
play and it wasted no time wowing them
with the pristine fight scenes and very
intriguing story it's just a shame that
this one ended in such a confusing
manner they did an anime original ending
right after starting to tease us with
the big overarching plot because they
probably figured out they wanted an
action finale which wasn't anywhere near
that manga stopping point still the
confusing ending does little to bring
down the enjoyment of the show and i
dare say that the first two-thirds of
gleiphner is legitimately a great show
if you're up for edgy fights a dark
atmosphere and some cool dynamics
between the two contrasting leads
at number seven my pick is glyph near
season mate tower of god
those were the days weren't they back
then there was this movement to bring
korean webtoons in anime former and what
better one to start the movement off
than probably the most popular webtoon
of them all tower of god combining a lot
of the familiar story beats with a very
creative setting and a lot of great
world building and cool characters and
action it's no surprise tower of god
became as famous as it did amongst the
shows i've talked about so far it's
probably the most focused on exploration
and adventure over fights in a sense if
it's the traditional explorative mould
that people have grown to love it's also
got a story that while not as deep or
profound as decadence relatively
speaking it does have its fair share of
substance my only gripe however is that
the entire season is basically the
prologue yeah you've heard that right as
a standalone it does very well and i
really enjoyed it but i think of what it
could have been sure it will get better
soon but i don't see this getting a
second season anytime soon it's a
glorified commercial even more so than
the standard manga or light novel
adaptations and i feel because of that
it's such a waste for number six i'll go
for 86.
[Music]
honestly i haven't had too many chances
to enjoy military anime the past few
years mecca shows i do watch and there
are some great hits from the past
decades like code geass and gundam ibo
there are also fringe military shows as
in barely qualify as one in certain
angles like kimi-san that i enjoyed but
if we're going with something that
speaks more to us in a societal level
coupled with a sci-fi backdrop that's
more of a few decades into the future
instead of a century or millennia it's a
bit harder to find shows like 86. it's a
testament to how unique 86 feels sci-fi
and military aren't rare but the way
it's delivered and how much it acts as
both an exciting action drama a society
study and an ultimately heartwarming
tale of trials and tribulations doesn't
seem as common it's got a little of
everything you'd want from the genre i
dare say that compared to a lot of the
hits that i'll be going over in the
second half it's even more profound and
has themes that speak heavily to the
world at large unfortunately military
and socio-philosophical commentary just
doesn't seem to be as mainstream which
is why it's just a six it's not
underappreciated or anything like that
not at all it's just that given the
package it's in it just finds it hard to
truly break into the mainstream
oh and if you've been enjoying the video
so far good why don't you hit that
little subscribe button and give the
channel a hand i'm happy that a lot of
you guys are enjoying the videos but i'm
finding a large percentage are still not
subscribed so if that's you and you fall
into that category then i would
absolutely love to encourage you to
subscribe like and share the video
my fifth place pick is tokyo revengers
mikey
now here's where the big mainstream hits
start coming in tokyo revenge is by far
has become one of the landmark shows of
2021 combining shonen fair with the time
travel premise that pops up a couple of
times a year yielded what many people
heralded as a unique battle shonen well
unique is probably not something i'll
crown it with completely it does feel
like a change of pace from the
superheroes the demonic powers the fire
breathing the super athletic sword
fights and whatnot it's also more packed
with drama and the gritty atmosphere
you'd expect from a show about
delinquents i give tokyo revenge's
praise mostly for its consistency in
terms of atmosphere it stays consistent
with its tone what it wants to do and
doesn't flip-flop between serious
dramatic moments to comedy that comes
out of nowhere it's a show that derives
its strength from the mature setup for a
battle shonen its attractive premise and
how it manages to hold everything
together in a package all throughout the
run that's probably why it's as popular
as it ended up being
is
here's something that i had mixed
expectations for all we knew about it is
that it was a music oriented action show
with a sci-fi backdrop and that somehow
re-zero guys were behind it dape in
sci-fi and one with terminator light
vibes combined with music truly an
interesting blend of things right it's
easy to look at the special effects and
praise vv is excellent in fields like
music art and awe-inspiring fight scenes
some which i feel holed up damn well a
year after its airing taken down to the
bare bones vivi is a thriller anime that
looks and sounds good and in the fields
it does well it does really well the
amusing thing about vivi however is that
it's one of the shows that i feel
resonate this strongly when it comes to
talking about society's growing infusion
with technology and all the dangers that
come with it it's got some themes that
look more and more relevant the more
years we go through in this world vivi
unlike similar shows like ghost in the
shell may not be remembered in the
slightest years from now heck i feel
it's largely faded from the public
sphere already actually but there's no
doubting its message its core value is a
sci-fi thriller and how fun the ride it
took me through when i first watched it
if we're talking just 2021 it has a case
for being one of the best shows that
that year gave us at third let's look at
ranking of kings
here's a show that's very easy to give a
pass just look at how it looks granted i
fell into the same trap but i eventually
came around to watching it and have to
say that i was blown away for how
simplistic it looks ranking of kings
manages to weave an underdog story for
the ages there's so much that people
give ranking of kings praise for there's
the plot itself there's the music and
presentation and there's a way in which
it creates drama and stakes now i agree
with all of those but for me the
strongest one must be in how it
presented the characters every notable
character no matter how small they are
in the grand scheme of things feels
really fleshed out with their
motivations and character roots ranking
of kings is a classic example of the
famous saying to never judge a book by
its cover its art style unfortunately
holds it back from being blind watched
by people randomly browsing the seasonal
lists looking for something new to watch
but i assure you the journey is worth it
second place is mushoku tensei
how could we talk about the top action
anime of the past few years without
talking about this it's long considered
the pioneer of the whole slew of middle
ages isakai that has oversaturated the
genre so the hype was there there's no
denying what mushoku tensei brings to
the table it's been a while since i've
seen this much love given to adapting a
series where else can you see a studio
being open for the sake of continually
animating a series for years to come it
brings us a visually stunning art a
character who would work for redemption
and strength a thrilling story of
adventure and growth through challenges
and some of the best world building
we've had in isekai for quite some time
it's not without his wrinkles but
putting those aside there's no doubt
that mushoku tensei is one of the most
complete isakai out there it's not
exactly profound or anything like some
of the stuff i've showcased prior but
you can really feel the care given to
its adaptation controversies and all
there's no doubt that mushoku tensei has
a case for being one of the shows the
2020s will be remembered for years to
come for good or bad it depends on your
perspective
for me the top spot belongs to jujutsu
kaizen
it is too early to tell but at the time
of this writing it's clear that jujutsu
kaizen is the battle shonen of the 2020s
i won't call it the best at anything but
in everything things are above average
to great it's got a premise that opens
potential for growth while being easy to
get into it's got a cast that comes in a
whole spectrum of character types the
sound and art is good and it both some
of the best animation we've seen from
new shows the past two years the
excellent production or help elevate the
already interesting magic system when we
do see it come into play creating a lot
of memorable moments and battles a lot
which i've talked about on the channel
you can tell that it kind of feels like
a formula a blueprint for success but
having a blueprint alone isn't enough
see a lot of the one and done battle
shonen but for jiu jitsu kaizen to be
making this kind of legacy for itself is
something the anime team must give
themselves a pat on the back for in the
same vein as wire plays mushoku tensei
ii we just can't ignore its influence in
the number of anime fans it managed to
connect through its popularity it's a
show that i feel partially buoyed off
demon slayer's popularity and brought
back to life the whole genre of
supernatural urban fantasy that was
popular back then with shows like shaman
king and bleach
so how does my list compare to yours
tell me in the comments section what
your top action animate of 2020 to 22r
if you've got more time then don't
forget to check out the channel for
videos that you might enjoy so hit the
subscribe button and don't forget to
check out revantasia the links in the
description once again thanks for
watching i hope that you'll have a great
day ahead and i'm looking forward to
seeing you again thank you
[Music]